hello america i'm mark levin and this is
life liberty and levin
over 40 years ago i was a school board
member in cheltenham township
pennsylvania outside of philadelphia
and i remember we had some raucous
meetings back then we didn't call in the
fbi or the department of justice of
course
that would have been absurd as it is
today
but the issues today are actually more
important
have you ever wondered why the democrats
don't denounce critical race theory
critical race theory is critical racism
theory
it is bigotry it is racism
it was born out of the 1970s its
founding father was derek bell who was a
marxist law professor at harvard
he was considered fringe back then and
his scholarship was considered shoddy if
scholarship at all
and you see how this has spread like
poison through our colleges and
universities throughout body politic and
now
in your elementary schools middle
schools and high schools
and you're being told to sit down and
shut up and just take it
there's a very very important
gubernatorial race in the state of
virginia as you know because these
issues are front and center and these
issues affect every corner of the united
states every classroom in the united
states
critical race theory has been embraced
by the democrat party by the media by
joe biden who has enshrined it with
executive orders
there is propaganda brainwashing going
on in our schools today pushing critical
race theory and if we don't put an end
to this we're going to destroy this
society we're going to destroy this
country we're going to destroy the
family structure faith and all the rest
why
because it's marxism as i said it was
born at harvard law school by a fellow
named derrick bell
and he was a marxist it's being pushed
by marxist and that is the founding
ideology behind this theory think about
it
oppressor and oppressed
if you are a certain race
you're oppressed even if you're not in
your own life oppressed you're oppressed
because you're that race if you're
another race you're an oppressor
regardless you might be the most
righteous human being on the face here
it doesn't matter because you're white
and that's how this works so instead of
the proletariat in the bourgeoisie as
mark set it up
you have the oppressed and the oppressor
white versus all minorities this is the
americanization
of marxism and it is pernicious
so let's get started here we're going to
have two great guests the republican
candidate for governor in virginia glenn
younkin and also the lieutenant governor
candidate in virginia winsome sears and
we want to talk to both of them but
first
a quick redo we had this letter from the
national school board association
september 29
2021 an inside job with the biden
administration of the department of
justice they colluded they coordinated
they conspired to go after parents
parents grandparents taxpayers citizens
who had serious concerns about critical
race theory and this transgender
movement a movement and other things
going on in our schools to indoctrinate
our children in what is democrat party
ideology and marxist ideology and in
part you'll recall that letter said
these acts of malice violence and
threats against public school officials
by parents have increased the
classification of these heinous actions
could be the equivalent to a form of
domestic terrorism and hate crimes as
such the national school boards
association requests a joint expedited
review by the united states department
of justice education homeland security
along with the appropriate training
coordination investigations and
enforcement mechanisms from the fbi
including any technical assistance
necessary from and state and local
coordination with its national security
branch and counterterrorism division
so what happened
what happened after this phony letter
was sent first of all the woman who
signed it got a job two days later in
the bible administration at the
education department are you aware of
that they not only coordinated with
biden in the department of justice they
coordinated we believe with the teachers
unions and others
five days later a memo miraculously
appears as you well know signed by
merrick garland we talked about it here
first on life liberty and levin and
among other things in this very short
memo in the coming days the department
will announce a series of measures
designed to address the rise in criminal
conduct directed towards school
personnel
when garland was asked about this he
couldn't point to examples of the rise
of criminal conduct against school
personnel it says i am directing the fbi
working with each u.s attorney to
convene meetings with federal state
local tribal territorial leaders in each
federal judicial district within 30 days
of the issuance of this memorandum these
meetings will facilitate the discussion
of strategies for addressing threats
against school administrators board
members teachers and staff will open
dedicated lines of communications for
threat reporting assessment and response
as if it's domestic terrorism
they have no examples of violence
certainly no pattern of violence
whatsoever as we discussed
and now we know scott smith who was used
by the national school boards
association the national media the biden
white house merrick garland and others
as an example violence the man wasn't
violent in the least violence was done
to him and his family his daughter had
been raped
raped in the girls room at stonebridge
high school in loudoun county virginia
where my kids went to school
raped it was covered up they lied the
school board and the superintendent to
the people of loudoun county
that boy was sent to another high school
where he raped again and he's been found
guilty since by a juvenile court
meanwhile merrick garland has not
withdrawn this memo and the school board
has not asked him to withdraw this memo
but now we have additional information
that local law enforcement in loudoun
county the loudoun county sheriff's
office was appalled by what the school
board was doing as fox reported new
documents obtained by fox news shed
light on apparent conflict and
frustration loud and law enforcement had
with the school board including a
complaint that the board should have let
residents speak at an explosive meeting
on june 22. emails also show loudoun
county sheriff's office rejecting what
it said were extraordinary security
measures including an explosive sweep
and undercover presence by the
superintendents for future school board
meetings in an august 6 email
superintendent scott ziegler requested
multiple loudoun county
deputies a five person quick reaction
force undercover deputies at the
administrative building a special
operations team on standby and several
other provisions
now the loudoun county sheriff mike
chapman who's a good man i know him
personally
said stick it
we're not doing that to the people
allowed in the county we're not doing to
their parents there's no justification
for this
yet the feds still have that memo out
where they want to target loudoun county
every single school district where
parents dare to speak out with their
domestic terrorism hotline so if a
teacher a union member a school board
member oh
i feel threatened they call and the fbi
shows up it's outrageous these are
parents that's what this election about
is in virginia and the rest of the
country these are parents who want a
quality education loudoun county if not
the riches is one of the richest
counties in the country
known for its school system and the
school s.a.t and other results are going
down they're plummeting because of the
ideological agenda of the american
marxist and the democrat party and the
teachers unions and the educational
bureaucrats and the superintendents
associations and you have parents here
who are standing up democrats
independents and republicans meanwhile
meanwhile at a hearing the senate
judiciary committee dick durbin the
number two democrat in the senate what
does he say about these parents these
are not routine people and sensed or
angry these are people who are acting
out their feelings in a violent manner
over and over again the same people we
see on airplanes and other places some
of whom we saw here on january 6 really
senator
how about the people we saw with black
lives matter and antifa are they the
ones pushing the critical race theory
ideology how come you've never denounced
black lives matter or critical race
theory ever why is that then barack
obama must leave one of his
multi-million dollar mansions or a
200-foot yacht with one of his
billionaire friends to fly into loudoun
county for a few hours to fly into
virginia to help his friend terry
mcauliffe
tara mcauliffe whose policies are
identical to joe biden's whether it's
inflation or taxes uh whether it is
immigration and so forth barack obama
breitbart writes cause outcry over
loudoun county rape cover up phony
trumped up culture war we don't have
time to be wasted on these phony trumped
up culture wars this fake outrage the
right wing media pedals to juice their
ratings this is obama
now the response to that was quick and
harsh that barack obama is ignoring
covering up
rape that took place in the loudoun
county public school system and
apparently there's more of this under
investigation now
and obama makes this statement now a
judge has found this man this kid
so-called guilty of rape but obama comes
in they don't care about the rape victim
they don't care about the education of
the children they don't care about the
concerns of the parents how do we know
this terry mcauliffe has said throughout
this race this gubernatorial campaign
that this radical racist ideology is a
racist dog whistle that his opponent
glenn younkin is using to divide the
people a racist dog whistle now parents
and the rest of us have been watching
over the last year and a half
when there was virtual education and we
saw what these kids were being taught
there are people making millions writing
books that are being used in these
classrooms there are people making
millions writing software that are used
in these classrooms and here we have
virginia's department of education is
promoting a book again fox that says
teachers must embrace theories such as
critical race theory despite the fact
that mcauliffe says we don't do that in
virginia the department's website
provides resources for its equity
initiatives which includes a tab titled
what we are reading and the list
comprised of resources the equity office
recommends and references in its work
includes books by anti-racist so-called
advocate ibrahim x kennedy
and abolitionist teaching network
co-founder bettina love
quote lastly she writes teachers must
embrace theories such as critical race
theories settler colonialism black
feminism disability and ability critical
race studies and other critical theories
that have the ability to interrogate
anti-blackness love wrote and we want to
do more than survive and it goes on and
on
but mcauliffe said it's a dog whistle
it's a dog whistle you know there's a
reason the former governor
of virginia an african-american the
first african-american governor and so
far the last african-american governor
douglas wilder has condemned terry
mcauliffe
he said you ran in a primary democrat
primary against two black women
and defeated them
you did almost nothing as governor for
the black community
he condemned kamala harris for swinging
into virginia
with her videos
and he said you've now exposed over 300
black churches
to tax audits and worse perhaps pulling
their charitable
foundation
and so he's condemned them both
and he said it's not about the democrat
party it's about the citizens of
virginia including the black citizens of
virginia and the democrat party has lost
connection with them
and that's the bottom line it's lost
connection with the entire country
critical race theory a marxist racist
theory that turns american against
american the democrat party not only
embraces it it celebrates it and
promotes it from its presidents to its
members of congress to its school boards
and the thugs that leave their teacher
units
when we come back
glenn younkin and winston sears hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else